[Music]
would you like to live on the moon yes I
would you would you'd like to be one of
the first people to go yes
[Music]
we have one of the most challenging
assignments that has ever been given to
modern man
the United States man and space program
is at least eight months behind out of
the Soviet Union now it is time to take
longest rise time for this nation to
take a clearly leading role in space
achievement it's there
we'd be neglecting our duties as people
if we didn't try to investigate it yeah
look at that picture over there
looky earth coming up wow that's pretty
you well maybe the first man on the moon
how do you personally feel about it well
I have the same desires at all the
astronauts we'd all like to make that
trip
go for landing all right they should be
within 5 miles of their landing points
how about you look about they're going
to go pick up that and gaudy baby eagle
has landed
we got to get down
[Music]
we got born a problem they stand by
their attained we're looking at it
it's a stepping stone to deeper space it
is no longer a dream but a reality
you
[Music]